jean pierre qui va commencer par mo eric
tu vas commencer par me éric away mois
éric le ni oui ni non tu vas les auprès
de lui alors attention je vous rappelle
c'est le début d'une union de la promo
si vous perdez il y aura une minute pour
dire ni oui ni non
si vous perdez je fais une petite promo
si vous gagnez je ferai attention sépare
aujourd'hui au collège attention c'est
parti pour tous de la ville rose
toulouse est une ville rose une vie vers
toulouse est une ville de 1,5
toulouse est une belle ville le musée
toulouse lautrec il y a le musée
toulouse lautrec à ce type d'achats
calculé je t'ai y avait beaucoup de
choses lui quoi il avait du verre tonnes
il avait du vent pour ces raisons il
avait des vins ils avaient d alcool vous
n'avez pas à vous on se connaît c'est
l'équité ou début de carrière sa
carrière sa carrière était magnifique et
la nôtre est une autre carrière on n'est
pas les serres les uns tu vas les
microsites si je vais bien j'ai bien
joué un bon jour c'est normal c'est
votre métier
on peut déjà se dit content gagner
[Applaudissements]
toute la france ça va être le nouveau
spectacle camping cars for ever au
casino de paris aussi du 27 février au
1er mars 2020 et le 20 et 21 février à
broadway vous entendez bien oui à
broadway à new york puis en tournée dans
toute la france
[Applaudissements]
je suis tellement heureux que la carte
bah oui ça fait longtemps qu'on se
croise concert rock roches hôtes en bout
et à chaque fois demain soir bien sûr
ils sont sûrs s'est vite on sait que ça
va cartonner
d'ailleurs je voulais j'oublie la
semaine dernière j'ai dit ah je suis
content il ya des chevaliers du fiel
après moi sur ces vite je sais que je
vais cartonné mais il ya un truc ne
s'est jamais raconté dis-moi année au
tout début on tient et une autre sur une
chaîne de télé on où on allait discuter
pour essayer de vendre la chaîne comédie
des petits bouts de trucs
ouais et on était dans le taxi et
francis et à l'époque les gens ne
connaissaient pas et où on essayait de
vendre des images 3d des gags et on
aille sur le trottoir devant la lui la
chaîne et il y avait un mec avec un
micro qui tourne à un sketch et qui
était totalement à poil et jédir francis
ce mec je ne sais pas qui c'est et
personne ne te connaissais j'ai dit mais
c'est sûr que le mec s'il est capable de
faire ça il y arrivera fin de la saison
10e mais qui n'a pas de but mais il a
des couilles
kerry ça va cracher que du prix alain du
sed les hommes et femmes dont m'asseoir
sur s'est vite voilà je vous le dis
loupez pas parce que c'est un inédit
merci en tout cas si tu vas être est ce
là jean-pierre allez vas-y lé pas
attention nous répéter ce qu'il dit
attention le sportif car j'ai un prix
tanzi tiny pauvreté champion de la haute
garonne dans quelle catégorie à a aucune
en fait ça c'était une invention des
recchi a fait une fausse dourges et tout
le monde me reprend ça que je fais du
sport je fais du sport je suis non joker
bouder on va parler chapeau à ces partis
minutes on va parler chapeau parle au
chapeau que penses tu devrais surveiller
que voit que portait montrichard 10k
japon mais quel chapeau à chapeau boulot
non c'est moi je restaure vous avais dit
le mot qu'il fallait pas dire la mêlée
posséder
oui dumas merde
[Musique]
van damme est imbattable
oui d'air il est en spectacle avec
booder is back
voilà ils sont tous les dimanches au
grand point virgule à 17h30 et en
tournée dans toute la france
exceptionnel vous dire je vous le dis
allez le voir
[Applaudissements]
et voilà affections oculaires en huit
films sachez qu'il a fait plus de 6
millions d'entrées au cinéma aussi clair
pour dire que c'est énorme bravo et
marc-antoine je vais faire jean claude
van damme n'a dit tenté par jean-claude
enchanté ont ce temps le butin bonjour
j'aimerais commencer de nid d'amour avec
un personnage est terminée avec un autre
personnage
j'aime l'avait tout simplement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean-jacques malpot panne fenway
baignoire ou qu'est ce que tu peux par
un cyril mais les choix
j'écris envir plusieurs façons bah je
sais pas quoi vous dire qu'ils avaient
tué aujourd'hui la météo s'est il va
faire j'adore j'ai l'impression labro
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pierre paquet dit traité au théâtre de
l'alhambra d'affaires carton il appuie
actuellement en tournée dans toute la
france
dans ton show inédit on a vu plein de
voix ce soir tu nous a régalés sur rfm
dans la matinale le meilleur des réveils
avec sa chronique le bret du faux et
c'est que c'est plein écoute tous les
matchs aller al bazi qui a perdu la
semaine dernière c'était possible que
nous survivions à cette soirée à un
parfait ici aussi c'est là que nous
serions que nous savons nous survivions
a presque fait sur les vieilles âmes non
seulement survécu puce moi collée
survécu de quoi gérer qu sion jeudi sur
la question
c'est dire le jeu ce soir miss tic a
entraîné cette semaine
christelle chollet attention moi cristal
c'est à toi les mains d'un homme qu'est
ce que ça représente pour vous le
travail et caresse ou la sauvegarde le
travail
jean-pierre la première s oui l'écart
est à gueule elle dit à gauche s'est dit
à gallas qui me souffle avait des choses
répond oui et quanta de la tour eiffel
pour les dernière de son spectacle
numéro 5 de cholet caf un carton sur ces
huit c'était sabia il ya trois semaines
c'est ton 5e one man show est vraiment
elle est exceptionnelle
[Applaudissements]
or hier ça évite d'avoir osé mettre en
prennent un spectacle philharmonie et je
vais te dirais tu as fait un carton
d'audience
je te le dis et bravo à toi
[Applaudissements]
pour toi les chronos et chantôme pour
bien pense que le sexe est un avant une
taille la blue bar deuxième question en
français combien sont tombés glee
en ce temps amour un grand groupe est en
tout cas c'est sûr certains sûr et
certain et la vie est belle ça va bien
tu sais quoi jean pierre j'ai envie de
dire oui j'en arrive qu'on trouve en
tournée dans toute la france avec le
spectacle il était une fois jean marie
bigard le spectacle de maddie déjà 4
deux casquettes et qui sera à l'olympia
le jeudi 27 février mais c'est complet
complet complet complet
[Applaudissements]
lolo qui peut jouer allez vas-y mollo
commandes brutes de jean pierre sang
froid allez vas-y mon lolo vas-y vas-y
un avis commun chez capello d'une chine
allez on y va de 60 secondes
absolument angélique je ne m'attendais
parce que vous me décevez vielles à
l'imparfait ici mon petit ça donne des
sceaux via ce nom non disent je ne
m'attendais pas à ce que vous me disiez
c'est possible caparros pas tout de
suite
djaballah pas dans l'immédiat si c'est
non j'ai pas droit à y associer mes
soucis
d'accord il lui fallut d'abord que vous
le 6 il ça c'est dans feydeau bidon
feydeau c'est pourtant le suis avec toi
toujours je t'aime a fini à l'afflux
quand je viens à dire que se tient trop
dit samba argent amour fichiers mais
encore sexe magouille et culture
générale 3,10 à tourner sa tournée
cinquante cinq ans dans toute la france
dans toute la france et toute la france
a entendu ta vous intriguer les gens
adorent ils adorent de kif et auditifs
de sur cliff
[Musique]
le ca
[Applaudissements]
m
assemblée et
jean pierre a fait jeudi le plus jeune
qui nous regardent c'est une légende de
la tv c'est un très très très très grand
monsieur
c est mon jean pierre donc je suis fier
que tu sois avec vous et je te le dis
vraiment un type formidable voilà je
t'aime fort